sharp man oh well you know I
gotta try your best
I like little monochromatic number you
got going it's just it's just a little
thing I had in the back of my closet
Wes and Jason have nothing but Rave
things to say about you from their time
on set with you for this film they even
said that you were just the ultimate at
tour you had a notepad that you would
carry around and jot down little notes
so what notes were you taking on set
here for this film I was writing don't
forget my lines don't forget my lines
don't forget my lines seriously though
what were you no it's one of those
things where you know actors always want
to have as much information
that we can use then as handles or grips
so the more that we can grip onto
something the more stable we feel does
that make sense so that when you learn
your lines but you also know a little
bit more about the character uh your apt
to remember those lines and it connects
to different things intellectually or
emotionally and just so it's it's just
writing down little things and ideas and
thoughts yeah I'm totally into taker too
and like seeing it helps me believe it
remember it put it into practice there
is something about not just thinking it
but actually sending it through your
body writing it down and I think it's
it's better for me if I write it down in
in cursive than on a computer ditto
oh my God
oh my God for a young woman
but okay
okay actors in This film her character
is mid she's a movie star so at one
point she wears grease paint on her face
to betray a black eye right so she can
nail this upcoming role of hers what is
the wildest thing that you've done to
encourage someone to cast you in a role
uh I um
I was playing in a character who was uh
being accused of a crime and I was angry
over it and I I said I tell you let me
out of here and I I took my fists and I
slammed it into the wall and I actually
punctured the wall it was a very thin
wall I put a hole in the wall and then
had to put your hands crack my hand
and I looked over to the to the people
auditioning me and they were like did
you get the Rope no no no no no no once
that happens it's over there oh my God
he's going to sue us he's going to sue
us and we're gonna is there hand okay
they're completely not thinking of the
character
tell me this Ryan have you and Robin
mapped out your travels for the time
that you're hitting pause on acting so
you can enjoy some time with your wife I
you know we haven't mapped it out we're
thinking about in a few years to come
just to kind of Escape for a little bit
yeah
and um reacquaint with each other it's
about been 34 years that we've been
married
thank you and we and I want to just
adjust the dynamic that we have between
us because it's been a whirlwind for me
for the past 25 years and she's been
going with me everywhere and I just kind
of want to even it out so it's not so
um once yeah there you go yeah will you
doing it well and good time good things
too
yeah all right we'll have fun tonight
congratulations you're always intrigued
to see stop it you are
foreign
[Music]